right we're on the internet how will a
jhin's displacing Latinos as the
fastest-growing group of immigrants
change our politics and society I turn
let me spin the magic 8-ball Mort Asians
over a Latinos will have fewer ELLs and
ours in our language I have to tell you
are certainly in New York City where I
come from are the most remarkable
community imaginable they're their most
serious they're the kids are wonderful
in school their parents are very
hard-working
they'll add to the movie sound like a
senator and godfather to know it's very
true I'm the other very high test scores
we've all cheated off them bill will you
admit you were wrong about the Miami
Miami Heat on your show you said the
heat would never win a title with LeBron
I did you said that I don't if I did I
was joking or hi yes can we vote oh
actually when it was actually you know
what I heard a lot of talk today on ESPN
about the people from Cleveland I guess
who are like hating on LeBron can I just
say you know what it's the American
dream to be able to move up and go ever
you want the people who said LeBron
James do we all want to be stuck in
Cleveland our whole life is that really
what America should be I mean it's a
fine City but if a man you know has the
opportunity to move that is what America
is about that's one of the great things
about it we still have fluidity and
ability to move anywhere and do whatever
we hate that LeBron didn't take them
with them yeah okay but we all can't
live in Miami right no the people have
the right to be pissed though is Seattle
right I mean Seattle got there guys
and taken to Oklahoma City in the dark
of night by a guy who said he wouldn't
do that and then they go to the finals
okay if the Supreme Court strikes down
the health care bill how in the world is
Obama going to turn that into a positive
for his campaign I don't think he is I
don't think he is there's no way to turn
that there is I mean there's it's it'll
be it'll be a loss because that's a big
signature legislative achievement it'll
also be economically bad for the country
I think because I'm crazy I mean this
Supreme Court is kind of a out there
Supreme Court and to the extent that
people want a Supreme Court that is less
radically conservative they may be
motivated in a way right
weren't before to step up for Obama so
that there's some hope of it there not
being more you know simply as a people
no longer think the Supreme Court is
neutral you had poll came out last week
Bush v Gore it was a bad start you also
have to recognize I mean that as bad as
Obama the economy is and all of that
type of stuff he is running against Mitt
Romney and Mitt Romney I ruined to go
back to the Latino issue Barack Obama
has deported record numbers of Latinos
while in office
and yet he's winning the Latino vote
which tells you all you need to know
about that run right he's winning the
battle Walker's vote he's been worse on
that yeah I mean sweet Jesus he kills a
lot of people he might be dead in the
Mormon oh yeah yeah he might begin the
Mormon vote what about the single-payer
coming back because right that is the
solution that is a real solution they
have it in Canada and they have a much
higher leader for a single-payer I am
put it there absolutely are you are you
Bobby I'm shocked
are you buying all I'm interested in is
a very good health care system at a
reasonable cost right and that is in New
York City alone if you put a $250,000
cap on damages okay up from from legal
from litigation okay you would save six
hundred million dollars for the
hospitals in New York just on that issue
who's holding that up I don't know who's
holding tort
how much tort reform affects health
about 1% but what is not really the
answer that the app people who advocate
single-payer don't want that type of
liability I mean with the single-payer
thing like here's everybody can become a
scientist on this you can do a
scientific assessment of how
single-payer would be liked by the
American people ask an old person if
they like their Medicare right Tippett
that's them if they like their Medicare
and ask them what they think about an
idea to actually make it private
insurance instead wait even even a tea
bag about what tea baggers love their
medication yeah ask don't ask old people
because old people cover about a third
of the cost through premiums of what
Medicare costs Medicare is a system
where literally everybody who pays into
it gets more out of it eventually than
they put in it is the definition of
unsustainable Medicare is not a model
for anything other than totally blowing
the budget what would be awesome is if
everybody was covered under Medicare
then you could do some real cost
controls in it and then yeah but again I
mean unlike Bush's programs Obama care
is actually paid for I mean this is part
of what is different about this
president is that he bit into the
Cadillac plan or Medicare Advantage okay
there are advisory boards for keeping
like the old mention of Medicaid it's
just a huge number for this it's the 18
or 19 million people who are covered
under Medicaid that's a huge blow out of
the medical cost but again we don't
blink an eye
at the money that we should have been
spending on perpetual warfare we
literally don't even it isn't we don't
sit here and go whoa trillions of
trillions of dollars for warfare we do
over here but when we're but when we're
we're talking about health care which is
our people and their well-being we're
shocked that it should cost us some
money here's a question and this might
be something that we
that's it have to be okay you know I
mean because you know the the defense
budget has essentially doubled over
about the past dozen years it should be
half at the very least as a starting
point and then we can take it down to
what we actually need to defend
ourselves but it's the same thing with
Medicare Medicare has gone up
tremendously and it is a use it it is a
very profligate program that does not
deliver the quality of care for the
amount of money that we need to be fun
that's true the health care system as a
whole and so I think Mort is right into
focusing on the issue of it and it's
true it's important for everybody no
matter what your healthcare situation is
because it affects our economy so much
and that is that our health care is too
expensive and it is not enough to
justify the extra expensive reason you
look at the way that you have
all-inclusive systems around the world
and whatever you think of the
ideological nature of what they're doing
their costs are lower and they're they
deliver less health care and that and
I'm not saying like you know we this is
without being I don't want you if they
deliver less health care how come the UN
ranks the United States in health care
37 you could maybe two or five you could
say maybe the factual 37 we're not how
long did you go to the doctor as little
as possible okay well good your rare
then because Americans like to go to the
doctor and it's just and I'm not saying
you know I disagree with kind of
socialize or single it up your life but
what I'm saying is that likes to give
you exactly the price that you pay oh
I'm gonna have a barium enema for kicks
it'll like it Bryce you eat [ __ ] and get
sick the price you pay for spending less
on health care is less health care now
it's you and when you control your
lifestyle changes you know the best
thing that people can do to to reduce
healthcare costs is not smoke not drink
to excess exercise once in a while but
you know we're not going if we have a
single-payer health care system we're
not going to be able to get replacements
as quickly as we would now which is
certainly the case I think it's at least
as good as the United how much are you
worth how much my yeah I'm worth a good
hip replacement okay we got a lot you
know I mean you're like a billionaire
right so I don't know what's gonna be
hard I have another bad a bad knee too
and are you are you on a waiting list in
Canada or can you call up somebody and
get it why do we have to make a killing
though on making people live that's
right what's the ultimate problem with
Obamacare is not socialism it's
capitalism
no it's we gotta go thank you very much
Real Time with Bill Maher --nz ask bill
as guest your questions right after the
show
at hbo.com